The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK so let's start.
So today, we're going
to continue the
subject from last time.
And the subject is
random variables.
As we discussed, random
variables basically associate
numerical values with the
outcomes of an experiment.
And we want to learn how
to manipulate them.
Now to a large extent, what's
going to happen, what's
happening during this chapter,
is that we are revisiting the
same concepts we have
seen in chapter one.
But we're going to introduce
a lot of new notation, but
really dealing with the
same kind of stuff.
The only difference where we
go beyond the new notation,
the new concept in this chapter
is the concept of the
expectation or expected
values.
And we're going to learn how
to manipulate expectations.
So let us start with a quick
review of what we
discussed last time.
We talked about random
variables.
Loosely speaking, random
variables are random
quantities that result
from an experiment.
More precisely speaking,
mathematically speaking, a
random variable is a function
from the sample space to the
real numbers.
That is, you give me an outcome,
and based on that
outcome, I can tell you the
value of the random variable.
So the value of the random
variable is a function of the
outcome that we have.
Now given a random variable,
some of the numerical outcomes
are more likely than others.
And we want to say which ones
are more likely and
how likely they are.
And the way we do that is by
writing down the probabilities
of the different possible
numerical outcomes.
Notice here, the notation.
We use uppercase to denote
the random variable.
We use lowercase to denote
real numbers.
So the way you read this, this
is the probability that the
random variable, capital X,
happens to take the numerical
value, little x.
This is a concept that's
familiar from chapter one.
And this is just the new
notation we will be using for
that concept.
It's the Probability Mass
Function of the random
variable, capital X. So the
subscript just indicates which
random variable we're
talking about.
And it's the probability
assigned to
a particular outcome.
And we want to assign such
probabilities for all possibly
numerical values.
So you can think of this as
being a function of little x.
And it tells you how likely
every little x is going to be.
Now the new concept we
introduced last time is the
concept of the expected value
for random variable, which is
defined this way.
You look at all the
possible outcomes.
And you form some kind of
average of all the possible
numerical values over the random
variable capital X. You
consider all the possible
numerical values, and you form
an average.
In fact, it's a weighted average
where, to every little
x, you assign a weight equal to
the probability that that
particular little x is
going to be realized.
Now, as we discussed last time,
if you have a random
variable, you can take a
function of a random variable.
And that's going to be a
new random variable.
So if capital X is a random
variable and g is a function,
g of X is a new random
variable.
You do the experiment.
You get an outcome.
This determines the value of
X. And that determines the
value of g of X.
So the numerical value of g of
X is determined by whatever
happens in the experiment.
It's random.
And that makes it a
random variable.
Since it's a random variable,
it has an
expectation of its own.
So how would we calculate the
expectation of g of X?
You could proceed by just using
the definition, which
would require you to find the
PMF of the random variable g
of X. So find the PMF of g of X,
and then apply the formula
for the expected value
of a random
variable with known PMF.
But there is also a shortcut,
which is just a different way
of doing the counting and the
calculations, in which we do
not need to find the PMF of g
of X. We just work with the
PMF of the original
random variable.
And what this is saying is that
the average value of g of
X is obtained as follows.
You look at all the possible
results, the X's,
how likely they are.
And when that particular
X happens, this is
how much you get.
And so this way, you add
these things up.
And you get the average amount
that you're going to get, the
average value of g of X, where
you average over the
likelihoods of the
different X's.
Now expected values have some
properties that are always
true and some properties that
sometimes are not true.
So the property that is not
always true is that this would
be the same as g of the expected
value of X. So in
general, this is not true.
You cannot interchange function
and expectation,
which means you cannot reason
on the average, in general.
But there are some exceptions.
When g is a linear function,
then the expected value for a
linear function is the same as
that same linear function of
the expectation.
So for linear functions, so
for random variable, the
expectation behaves nicely.
So this is basically telling you
that, if X is degrees in
Celsius, alpha X plus b is
degrees in Fahrenheit, you can
first do the conversion
to Fahrenheit
and take the average.
Or you can find the average
temperature in Celsius, and
then do the conversion
to Fahrenheit.
Either is valid.
So the expected value tells us
something about where is the
center of the distribution, more
specifically, the center
of mass or the center of gravity
of the PMF, when you
plot it as a bar graph.
Besides the average value, you
may be interested in knowing
how far will you be from
the average, typically.
So let's look at this quantity,
X minus expected
value of X.
This is the distance from
the average value.
So for a random outcome of the
experiment, this quantity in
here measures how far
away from the mean
you happen to be.
This quantity inside the
brackets is a random variable.
Why?
Because capital X is random.
And what we have here is capital
X, which is random,
minus a number.
Remember, expected values
are numbers.
Now a random variable
minus a number is
a new random variable.
It has an expectation
of its own.
We can use the linearity rule,
expected value of something
minus something else is just
the difference of their
expected value.
So it's going to be expected
value of X minus the expected
value over this thing.
Now this thing is a number.
And the expected value
of a number is
just the number itself.
So we get from here that this
is expected value minus
expected value.
And we get zero.
What is this telling us?
That, on the average, the
assigned difference from the
mean is equal to zero.
That is, the mean is here.
Sometimes X will fall
to the right.
to the left.
On the average, the average
distance from the mean is
going to be zero, because
sometimes the realized
distance will be positive,
sometimes it will be negative.
Positives and negatives
cancel out.
So if we want to capture the
idea of how far are we from
the mean, just looking at the
assigned distance from the
mean is not going to give us
any useful information.
So if we want to say something
about how far we are,
typically, we should do
something different.
One possibility might be to take
the absolute values of
the differences.
And that's a quantity that
sometimes people are
interested in.
But it turns out that a more
useful quantity happens to be
the variance of a random
variable, which actually
measures the average squared
distance from the mean.
So you have a random outcome,
random results, random
numerical value of the
random variable.
It is a certain distance
away from the mean.
That certain distance
is random.
We take the square of that.
This is the squared distance
from the mean,
which is again random.
Since it's random, it has an
expected value of its own.
And that expected value, we call
it the variance of X. And
so we have this particular
definition.
Using the rule that we have up
here for how to calculate
expectations of functions
of a random variable,
why does that apply?
Well, what we have inside the
brackets here is a function of
the random variable, capital X.
So we can apply this rule
where g is this particular
function.
And we can use that to calculate
the variance,
starting with the PMF of the
random variable X. And then we
have a useful formula that's a
nice shortcut, sometimes, if
you want to do the
calculation.
Now one thing that's slightly
wrong with the variance is
that the units are not right, if
you want to talk about the
spread a of a distribution.
Suppose that X is a random
variable measured in meters.
The variance will have the
units of meters squared.
So it's a kind of a
different thing.
If you want to talk about the
spread of the distribution
using the same units as you have
for X, it's convenient to
take the square root
of the variance.
And that's something
that we define.
And we call it to the standard
deviation of X, or the
standard deviation of the
distribution of X. So it tells
you the amount of spread
in your distribution.
And it is in the same units as
the random variable itself
that you are dealing with.
And we can just illustrate
those quantities with an
example that's about as
simple as it can be.
So consider the following
experiment.
You're going to go from
here to New York,
let's say, 200 miles.
And you have two alternatives.
Either you'll get your private
plane and go at a speed of 200
miles per hour, constant speed
during your trip, or
otherwise, you'll decide to walk
really, really slowly, at
the leisurely pace of
one mile per hour.
So you pick the speed at
random by doing this
experiment, by flipping
a coin.
And with probability one-half,
you do one thing.
With probably one-half, you
do the other thing.
So your V is a random
variable.
In case you're interested in
how much time it's going to
take you to get there, well,
time is equal to distance
divided by speed.
So that's the formula.
The time itself is a random
variable, because it's a
function of V, which
is random.
How much time it's going to take
you depends on the coin
flip that you do in the
beginning to decide what speed
you are going to have.
OK, just as a warm up, the
trivial calculations.
To find the expected value of
V, you argue as follows.
With probability one-half,
V is going to be one.
And with probability one-half,
V is going to be 200.
And so the expected value
of your speed is 100.5.
If you wish to calculate the
variance of V, then you argue
as follows.
With probability one-half, I'm
going to travel at the speed
of one, whereas, the
mean is 100.5.
So this is the distance from
the mean, if I decide to
travel at the speed of one.
We take that distance from
the mean squared.
That's one contribution
to the variance.
And with probability one-half,
you're going to travel at the
speed of 200, which is this
much away from the mean.
You take the square of that.
OK, so approximately how
big is this number?
Well, this is roughly
100 squared.
That's also 100 squared.
So approximately, the variance
of this random
variable is 100 squared.
Now if I tell you that the
variance of this distribution
is 10,000, it doesn't
really help you to
relate it to this diagram.
Whereas, the standard deviation,
where you take the
square root, is more
interesting.
It's the square root of 100
squared, which is a 100.
And the standard deviation,
indeed, gives us a sense of
how spread out this distribution
is from the mean.
So the standard deviation
basically gives us some
indication about this spacing
that we have here.
It tells us the amount of spread
in our distribution.
OK, now let's look at what
happens to time.
V is a random variable.
T is a random variable.
So now let's look at the
expected values and all of
that for the time.
OK, so the time is a function
of a random variable.
We can find the expected time
by looking at all possible
outcomes of the experiment, the
V's, weigh them according
to their probabilities, and for
each particular V, keep
track of how much
time it took us.
So if V is one, which happens
with probability one-half, the
time it takes is going
to be 200.
If we travel at speed of one,
it takes us 200 time units.
And otherwise, if our speed is
equal to 200, the time is one.
So the expected value of T is
once more the same as before.
It's 100.5.
So the expected speed
is 100.5.
The expected time
is also 100.5.
So the product of these
expectations is
something like 10,000.
How about the expected value
of the product of T and V?
Well, T times V is 200.
No matter what outcome you have
in the experiment, in
that particular outcome, T
times V is total distance
traveled, which is
exactly 200.
And so what do we get in this
simple example is that the
expected value of the product of
these two random variables
is different than the product
of their expected values.
This is one more instance
of where we cannot
reason on the average.
So on the average, over a large
number of trips, your
average time would be 100.
On the average, over a large
number of trips, your average
speed would be 100.
But your average distance
traveled is not 100 times 100.
It's something else.
So you cannot reason on the
average, whenever you're
dealing with non-linear
things.
And the non-linear thing here
is that you have a function
which is a product of stuff,
as opposed to just
linear sums of stuff.
Another way to look at what's
happening here is the expected
value of the time.
Time, by definition, is
200 over the speed.
Expected value of the time, we
found it to be about a 100.
And so expected value of 200
over V is about a 100.
But it's different from this
quantity here, which is
roughly equal to
2, and so 200.
Expected value of
V is about 100.
So this quantity is about
equal to two.
Whereas, this quantity
up here is about 100.
So what do we have here?
We have a non-linear function
of V. And we find that the
expected value of this function
is not the same thing
as the function of the
expected value.
So again, that's an instance
where you cannot interchange
expected values and functions.
And that's because things
are non-linear.
OK, so now let us introduce
a new concept.
Or maybe it's not quite
So we discussed, in chapter
one, that we have
probabilities.
We also have conditional
What's the difference
between them?
Essentially, none.
Probabilities are just an
assignment of probability
values to give different
outcomes, given
a particular model.
Somebody comes and gives
you new information.
So you come up with
a new model.
And you have a new
probabilities.
We call these conditional
probabilities, but they taste
and behave exactly the same
as ordinary probabilities.
So since we can have conditional
probabilities, why
not have conditional PMFs as
well, since PMFs deal with
probabilities anyway.
So we have a random variable,
capital X. It has
a PMF of its own.
For example, it could be the PMF
in this picture, which is
a uniform PMF that takes for
possible different values.
And we also have an event.
And somebody comes
and tells us that
this event has occurred.
The PMF tells you the
probability that capital X
equals to some little x.
Somebody tells you that a
certain event has occurred
that's going to make you change
the probabilities that
you assign to the different
values.
You are going to use conditional
probabilities.
So this part, it's clear what
it means from chapter one.
And this part is just the new
notation we're using in this
chapter to talk about
conditional probabilities.
So this is just a definition.
So the conditional PMF
is an ordinary PMF.
But it's the PMF that applies
to a new model in which we
have been given some information
about the outcome
of the experiment.
So to make it concrete, consider
this event here.
Take the event that capital
X is bigger
than or equal to two.
In the picture, what
is the event A?
The event A consists of
these three outcomes.
OK, what is the conditional PMF,
given that we are told
that event A has occurred?
Given that the event A has
occurred, it basically tells
us that this outcome
has not occurred.
There's only three possible
outcomes now.
In the new universe, in the new
model where we condition
on A, there's only three
possible outcomes.
Those three possible outcomes
were equally
likely when we started.
So in the conditional universe,
they will remain
equally likely.
Remember, whenever you
condition, the relative
likelihoods remain the same.
They keep the same
proportions.
They just need to be
re-scaled, so that
they add up to one.
So each one of these will have
the same probability.
Now in the new world,
probabilities need
to add up to 1.
So each one of them is going to
get a probability of 1/3 in
the conditional universe.
So this is our conditional
model.
So our PMF is equal to 1/3 for
X equals to 2, 3 and 4.
All right.
Now whenever you have a
probabilistic model involving
a random variable and you have
a PMF for that random
variable, you can talk about
the expected value of that
random variable.
We defined expected values
just a few minutes ago.
Here, we're dealing with
a conditional model and
conditional probabilities.
And so we can also talk about
the expected value of the
random variable X in this new
universe, in this new
conditional model that
we're dealing with.
And this leads us to the
definition of the notion of a
conditional expectation.
The conditional expectation
is nothing but an ordinary
expectation, except that you
don't use the original PMF.
You use the conditional PMF.
You use the conditional
probabilities.
It's just an ordinary
expectation, but applied to
the new model that we have to
the conditional universe where
we are told that the certain
event has occurred.
So we can now calculate the
condition expectation, which,
in this particular example,
would be 1/3.
That's the probability of a
2, plus 1/3 which is the
probability of a 3 plus 1/3,
the probability of a 4.
And then you can use your
calculator to find the answer,
or you can just argue
by symmetry.
The expected value has to be the
center of gravity of the
PMF we're working with,
which is equal to 3.
So conditional expectations are
no different from ordinary
expectations.
They're just ordinary
expectations applied to a new
type of situation or a
new type of model.
Anything we might know about
expectations will remain valid
about conditional
expectations.
So for example, the conditional
expectation of a
linear function of a random
variable is going to be the
linear function of the
conditional expectations.
Or you can take any formula that
you might know, such as
the formula that expected value
of X is equal to the--
sorry--
expected value of g of X is the
sum over all X's of g of X
times the PMF of X. So this is
the formula that we already
know about how to calculate
expectations of a function of
a random variable.
If we move to the conditional
universe, what changes?
In the conditional universe,
we're talking about the
conditional expectation, given
that event A has occurred.
And we use the conditional
probabilities, given that A
has occurred.
So any formula has a conditional
counterpart.
In the conditional counterparts,
expectations get
replaced by conditional
expectations.
And probabilities get replaced
by conditional probabilities.
So once you know the first
formula and you know the
general idea, there's absolutely
no reason for you
to memorize a formula
like this one.
You shouldn't even have to write
it on your cheat sheet
for the exam, OK?
OK, all right, so now let's look
at an example of a random
variable that we've seen before,
the geometric random
variable, and this time do
something a little more
interesting with it.
Do you remember from last time
what the geometric random
variable is?
We do coin flips.
Each time there's a
probability of P
of obtaining heads.
And we're interested in the
number of tosses we're going
to need until we observe heads
for the first time.
The probability that the random
variable takes the
value K, this is the probability
that the first K
appeared at the K-th toss.
So this is the probability of
K minus 1 consecutive tails
followed by a head.
So this is the probability of
having to weight K tosses.
And when we plot this PMF, it
has this kind of shape, which
is the shape of a geometric
progression.
It starts at 1, and it goes
all the way to infinity.
So this is a discrete random
variable that takes values
over an infinite set, the set
of the positive integers.
So it's a random variable,
therefore, it has an
expectation.
And the expected value is, by
definition, we'll consider all
possible values of the
random variable.
And we weigh them according to
their probabilities, which
leads us to this expression.
You may have evaluated that
expression some time in your
previous life.
And there are tricks for how
to evaluate this and get a
closed-form answer.
But it's sort of an
algebraic trick.
You might not remember it.
How do we go about doing
this summation?
Well, we're going to use a
probabilistic trick and manage
to evaluate the expectation of
X, essentially, without doing
any algebra.
And in the process of doing so,
we're going to get some
intuition about what happens
in coin tosses and with
geometric random variables.
So we have two people who
are going to do the same
experiment, flip a coin until
they obtain heads for the
first time.
One of these people is going to
use the letter Y to count
how many heads it took.
So that person starts
flipping right now.
This is the current time.
And they are going to obtain
tails, tails, tails, until
eventually they obtain heads.
And this random variable Y is,
of course, geometric, so it
has a PMF of this form.
OK, now there is a second person
who is doing that same
experiment.
That second person is going to
take, again, a random number,
X, until they obtain heads
for the first time.
And of course, X is going to
have the same PMF as Y.
But that person was impatient.
And they actually started
flipping earlier, before the Y
person started flipping.
They flipped the coin twice.
And they were unlucky, and they
obtained tails both times.
And so they have to continue.
Looking at the situation at this
time, how do these two
people compare?
Who do you think is going
to obtain heads first?
Is one more likely
than the other?
So if you play at the casino a
lot, you'll say, oh, there
were two tails in a row, so
a head should be coming up
sometime soon.
But this is a wrong argument,
because coin flips, at least
in our model, are independent.
The fact that these two happened
to be tails doesn't
change anything about our
beliefs about what's going to
be happening here.
So what's going to be happening
to that person is
they will be flipping
independent coin flips.
That person will also
be flipping
independent coin flips.
And both of them wait until
the first head occurs.
They're facing an identical
situation,
starting from this time.
OK, now what's the probabilistic
model of what
this person is facing?
The time until that person
obtains heads for the first
time is X. So this number of
flips until they obtain heads
for the first time is going
to be X minus 2.
So X is the total number
until the first head.
X minus 2 is the number or
flips, starting from here.
Now what information do we
have about that person?
We have the information
that their first
two flips were tails.
So we're given the information
that X was bigger than 2.
So the probabilistic model that
describes this piece of
the experiment is that it's
going to take a random number
of flips until the first head.
That number of flips, starting
from here until the next head,
is that number X minus 2.
But we're given the information
that this person
has already wasted
2 coin flips.
Now we argued that
probabilistically, this
person, this part of the
experiment here is identical
with that part of
the experiment.
So the PMF of this random
variable, which is X minus 2,
conditioned on this information,
should be the
same as that PMF that
we have down there.
So the formal statement that
I'm making is that this PMF
here of X minus 2, given that
X is bigger than 2, is the
same as the PMF of X itself.
What is this saying?
Given that I tell you that you
already did a few flips and
they were failures, the
remaining number of flips
until the first head has the
same geometric distribution as
if you were starting
from scratch.
Whatever happened in the past,
it happened, but has no
bearing what's going to
happen in the future.
Remaining coin flips until
a head has the same
distribution, whether you're
starting right now, or whether
you had done some other
stuff in the past.
So this is a property that we
call the memorylessness
property of the geometric
distribution.
Essentially, it says that
whatever happens in the future
is independent from whatever
happened in the past.
And that's true almost by
definition, because we're
assuming independent
coin flips.
Really, independence means that
information about one
part of the experiment has no
bearing about what's going to
happen in the other parts
of the experiment.
The argument that I tried to
give using the intuition of
coin flips, you can make it
formal by just manipulating
PMFs formally.
So this is the original
PMF of X.
Suppose that you condition
on the event that X
is bigger than 3.
This conditioning information,
what it does is it tells you
that this piece did
not happen.
You're conditioning just
on this event.
When you condition on that
event, what's left is the
conditional PMF, which has the
same shape as this one, except
that it needs to be
re-normalized up, so that the
probabilities add up to one.
So you take that picture, but
you need to change the height
of it, so that these
terms add up to 1.
And this is the conditional
PMF of X, given that X is
bigger than 2.
But we're talking here not about
X. We're talking about
the remaining number of heads.
Remaining number of heads
is X minus 2.
If we have the PMF of X, can we
find the PMF of X minus 2?
Well, if X is equal to 3, that
corresponds to X minus 2 being
equal to 1.
So this probability here
should be equal to that
probability.
The probability that X is equal
to 4 should be the same
as the probability that X
minus 2 is equal to 2.
So basically, the PMF of X minus
2 is the same as the PMF
of X, except that it gets
shifted by these 2 units.
So this way, we have formally
derived the conditional PMF of
the remaining number of coin
tosses, given that the first
two flips were tails.
And we see that it's exactly
the same as the PMF that we
started with.
And so this is the formal proof
of this statement here.
So it's useful here to digest
both these formal statements
and understand it and understand
the notation that
is involved here, but also
to really appreciate the
intuitive argument what
this is really saying.
OK, all right, so now we want to
use this observation, this
memorylessness, to eventually
calculate the expected value
for a geometric random
variable.
And the way we're going to do
it is by using a divide and
conquer tool, which is an analog
of what we have already
seen sometime before.
Remember our story that there's
a number of possible
scenarios about the world?
And there's a certain event, B,
that can happen under any
of these possible scenarios.
And we have the total
probability theory.
And that tells us that, to find
the probability of this
event, B, you consider
the probabilities of
B under each scenario.
And you weigh those
probabilities according to the
probabilities of the different
scenarios that we have.
So that's a formula that
we already know
and have worked with.
What's the next step?
Is it something deep?
No, it's just translation
in different notation.
This is the exactly same
formula, but with PMFs.
The event that capital X is
equal to little x can happen
in many different ways.
It can happen under
either scenario.
And within each scenario, you
need to use the conditional
probabilities of that event,
given that this
scenario has occurred.
So this formula is identical to
that one, except that we're
using conditional PMFs,
instead of conditional
probabilities.
But conditional PMFs, of
course, are nothing but
conditional probabilities
anyway.
So nothing new so far.
Then what I do is to take this
formula here and multiply both
sides by X and take the
sum over all X's.
What do we get on this side?
We get the expected
value of X.
What do we get on that side?
Probability of A1.
And then here, sum over all
X's of X times P. That's,
again, the same calculation
we have when we deal with
expectations, except that, since
here, we're dealing with
conditional probabilities,
we're going to get the
conditional expectation.
And this is the total
expectation theorem.
It's a very useful way for
calculating expectations using
a divide and conquer method.
We figure out the average value
of X under each one of
the possible scenarios.
The overall average value of
X is a weighted linear
combination of the expected
values of X in the different
scenarios where the weights are
chosen according to the
different probabilities.
OK, and now we're going to apply
this to the case of a
geometric random variable.
And we're going to divide and
conquer by considering
separately the two cases where
the first toss was heads, and
the other case where the
first toss was tails.
So the expected value of X is
the probability that the first
toss was heads, so that X is
equal to 1, and the expected
value if that happened.
What is the expected value of X,
given that X is equal to 1?
If X is known to be
equal to 1, then X
becomes just a number.
And the expected value of a
number is the number itself.
So this first line here is the
probability of heads in the
first toss times the number 1.
So the probability that X is
bigger than 1 is 1 minus P.
And then we need to do
something about this
conditional expectation.
What is it?
I can write it in, perhaps,
a more suggested form, as
expected the value of X minus
1, given that X minus 1 is
bigger than 1.
Ah.
OK, X bigger than 1 is the
same as X minus 1 being
positive, this way.
X minus 1 is positive plus 1.
What did I do here?
I added and subtracted 1.
Now what is this?
This is the expected value of
the remaining coin flips,
until I obtain heads, given that
the first one was tails.
It's the same story that we were
going through down there.
Given that the first coin flip
was tails doesn't tell me
anything about the
future, about the
remaining coin flips.
So this expectation should be
the same as the expectation
faced by a person who was
starting just now.
So this should be equal to the
expected value of X itself.
And then we have the plus 1
that's come from there, OK?
Remaining coin flips until a
head, given that I had a tail
yesterday, is the same as
expected number of flips until
heads for a person just starting
now and wasn't doing
anything yesterday.
So the fact that they I had a
coin flip yesterday doesn't
change my beliefs about how
long it's going to take me
until the first head.
So once we believe that
relation, than
we plug this here.
And this red term becomes
expected value of X plus 1.
So now we didn't exactly get the
answer we wanted, but we
got an equation that involves
the expected value of X. And
it's the only unknown
in that equation.
Expected value of X equals to P
plus (1 minus P) times this
expression.
You solve this equation for
expected value of X, and you
get the value of 1/P.
The final answer does make
intuitive sense.
If P is small, heads are
difficult to obtain.
So you expect that it's going to
take you a long time until
you see heads for
the first time.
So it is definitely a
reasonable answer.
Now the trick that we used here,
the divide and conquer
trick, is a really nice one.
It gives us a very good shortcut
in this problem.
But you must definitely spend
some time making sure you
understand why this expression
here is the same as that
expression there.
Essentially, what it's saying is
that, if I tell you that X
is bigger than 1, that the first
coin flip was tails, all
I'm telling you is that that
person has wasted a coin flip,
and they are starting
all over again.
So they've wasted 1 coin flip.
And they're starting
all over again.
If I tell you that the first
flip was tails, that's the
only information that I'm
basically giving you, a wasted
flip, and then starts
all over again.
All right, so in the few
remaining minutes now, we're
going to quickly introduce a few
new concepts that we will
be playing with in the
next ten days or so.
And you will get plenty
of opportunities
to manipulate them.
So here's the idea.
A typical experiment may have
several random variables
associated with that
experiment.
So a typical student has
height and weight.
If I give you the PMF of
height, that tells me
something about distribution
of heights in the class.
I give you the PMF of weight,
it tells me something about
the different weights
in this class.
But if I want to ask a
question, is there an
association between height and
weight, then I need to know a
little more how height and
weight relate to each other.
And the PMF of height
individuality and PMF of
weight just by itself
do not tell me
anything about those relations.
To be able to say something
about those relations, I need
to know something about joint
probabilities, how likely is
it that certain X's go together
with certain Y's.
So these probabilities,
essentially, capture
associations between these
two random variables.
And it's the information I would
need to have to do any
kind of statistical study that
tries to relate the two random
variables with each other.
These are ordinary
probabilities.
This is an event.
It's the event that
this thing happens
and that thing happens.
This is just the notation
that we will be using.
It's called the joint PMF.
It's the joint Probability
Mass Function of the two
random variables X and Y looked
at together, jointly.
And it gives me the probability
that any
particular numerical outcome
pair does happen.
So in the finite case, you can
represent joint PMFs, for
example, by a table.
This particular table here would
give you information
such as, let's see, the joint
PMF evaluated at 2, 3.
This is the probability that
X is equal to 3 and,
simultaneously, Y
is equal to 3.
So it would be that
number here.
It's 4/20.
OK, what is a basic
property of PMFs?
First, these are probabilities,
so all of the
entries have to be
non-negative.
If you adopt the probabilities
over all possible numerical
pairs that you could get, of
course, the total probability
must be equal to 1.
So that's another thing
that we want.
Now suppose somebody gives
me this model, but I
don't care about Y's.
All I care is the distribution
of the X's.
So I'm going to find the
probability that X takes on a
particular value.
Can I find it from the table?
Of course, I can.
If you ask me what's the
probability that X is equal to
3, what I'm going to do is
to add up those three
probabilities together.
And those probabilities, taken
all together, give me the
probability that X
is equal to 3.
These are all the possible ways
that the event X equals
to 3 can happen.
So we add these, and
we get the 6/20.
What I just did, can we
translate it to a formula?
What did I do?
I fixed the particular value
of X. And I added up the
values of the joint PMF over all
the possible values of Y.
So that's how you do it.
You take the joint.
You take one slice of the joint,
keeping X fixed, and
adding up over the different
values of Y.
The moral of this example is
that, if you know the joint
PMFs, then you can find the
individual PMFs of every
individual random variable.
And we have a name for these.
We call them the
marginal PMFs.
We have the joint that talks
about both together, and the
marginal that talks about
them one at the time.
And finally, since we love
conditional probabilities, we
will certainly want to define
an object called the
conditional PMF.
So this quantity here
is a familiar one.
It's just a conditional
probability.
It's the probability that X
takes on a particular value,
given that Y takes
a certain value.
For our example, let's take
little y to be equal to 2,
which means that we're
conditioning to live inside
this universe.
This red universe here is the
y equal to 2 universe.
And these are the conditional
probabilities of the different
X's inside that universe.
OK, once more, just an
exercise in notation.
This is the chapter two version
of the notation of
what we were denoting this
way in chapter one.
The way to read this is that
it's a conditional PMF having
to do with two random variables,
the PMF of X
conditioned on information
about Y. We are fixing a
particular value of capital Y,
that's the value on which we
are conditioning.
And we're looking at the
probabilities of
the different X's.
So it's really a function
of two arguments, little
x and little y.
But the best way to think about
it is to fix little y
and think of it as a function
of X. So I'm fixing little y
here, let's say, to
y equal to 2.
So I'm considering only this.
And now, this quantity becomes
a function of little x.
For the different little x's,
we're going to have different
conditional probabilities.
What are those conditional
probabilities?
OK, conditional probabilities
are proportional to original
probabilities.
So it's going to be those
numbers, but scaled up.
And they need to be scaled
so that they add up to 1.
So we have 1, 3 and 1.
That's a total of 5.
So the conditional PMF would
have the shape zero,
1/5, 3/5, and 1/5.
This is the conditional PMF,
given a particular value of Y.
It has the same shape as those
numbers, where by shape, I
mean try to visualize
a bar graph.
The bar graph associated with
those numbers has exactly the
same shape as the bar graph
associated with those numbers.
The only thing that has changed
is the scaling.
Big moral, let me say in
different words, the
conditional PMF, given a
particular value of Y, is just
a slice of the joint PMF where
you maintain the same shape,
but you rescale the numbers
so that they add up to 1.
Now mathematically, of course,
what all of this is doing is
it's taking the original joint
PDF and it rescales it by a
certain factor.
This does not involve X, so the
shape, is a function of X,
has not changed.
We're keeping the same shape
as a function of X, but we
divide by a certain number.
And that's the number that we
need, so that the conditional
probabilities add up to 1.
Now where does this
formula come from?
Well, this is just the
definition of conditional
probabilities.
Probability of something
conditioned on something else
is the probability of both
things happening, the
intersection of the two divided
by the probability of
the conditioning event.
And last remark is that, as
I just said, conditional
probabilities are nothing
different than ordinary
probabilities.
So a conditional PMF must sum
to 1, no matter what you are
conditioning on.
All right, so this was sort of
quick introduction into our
new notation.
But you get a lot of practice
in the next days to come.